lorsqu'on sortait tous les deux juste
après notre rencontre nous étions
presque amoureux on se voyait
au jeu de honte
avant chaque rendez-vous je ne tenais
plus en place je me faisais balle pour
vous je m'y croyais
devant ma glace
et tout autour de ma bouche je
redessinais mes lèvres d'une très
subtile couche de rouge à
lèvres rouge
est-ce qu'il devait arriver
arriva jour où l'autre nous y étions
préparés chacun ses prix la main de
l'eau
alors tu t'es retourné pour me regarder
en face tu as été le premier tu as osé
briser la glace
alors tu as pris ma bouche pour y
patiner tes lèvres et faire des bords de
ma couche de rouge à lèvres
rouge
ouvert les yeux ça m'a fait le coup du
pain tu aurais fait des envieux chez les
du bois douleur
depuis on sait plus quitter mais je ne
me fais plus Banner c'est toi qui m'a
incité où tu me préfères plus naturel
mais dans nos jeux érotiques il m'arrive
parfois d'en mettre et nous élan
nostalgie ont toute une envie de
renaître
autour de ma bouche tu m'embrasses sur
mes lèvres pour faire des bandes de ma
couche de rouge à lèvres